fast and furious movies a tradition in
which every two years a movie theater
parking lot gets to look like this let's
do it Fast Five so admittedly I've only
seen the first fast in the Furious movie
and when I saw it I was like I was like
Point Break with cars if you haven't
seen Point Break yet see it and you'll
know
so in Fast Five this druglord and Rio de
Janeiro pretty much runs the place which
it's totally different side of Rio that
they show in this movie and Rio was like
oh nice and fun and hang gliding and
colors in Fast Five it's like crime and
drugs and machine guns yeah I don't want
to go there anymore and so Vin Diesel
and Paul Walker like all right in order
to take that guy down we're gonna take
his money so they get the entire crew
together which I recognize a lot of
people from the other Fast and Furious
trailers and after that it's like
Ocean's eleven with cars
there is one crew member I don't
recognize her from any of the trailers
but oh my god this chick is perfect she
is hot
I mean dead serious with you guys all
right you know all the girls that I've
said are hot and they're like my wives
and whatnot like Natalie Portman Anne
Hathaway and I'm pretty sure there was
one of this chick no no this is too
chick right here this chick is perfect
every time she's on screen the dialogue
just becomes all right we're gonna go oh
my god thanks God for making that chick
back to the plot so it's pretty much
that they're gonna steal this crime
bosses money
all the while Dwayne the rock Johnson is
on their trail he's like the FBI agent
who's after Paul Walker and Vin Diesel
at first when you see Dwayne Johnson
stroll up on the scene he's all hardcore
and he's just shouting out all the
one-liners you're like look at this guy
trying to be Tommy Lee Jones and the
fugitive and you're like all right he's
pretty cool and then you're like holy
[ __ ] I wouldn't want to cross that guy
ever
this guy's hardcore he's like Armageddon
yeah he the person is Armageddon there's
a scene where he and Vin Diesel are
fighting it reminded me of like Godzilla
versus pick a random humongous monster
it's pretty awesome I'm not going
through walls and [ __ ] that's what I'm
talking about
now in the start of this movie the first
like 20 minutes to half an hour I was
like I'm kind of bored but after that it
really kicks on they bring the crew
together and they're like doing test
runs for their you know Italian job or
Rio job and it starts getting cool then
everything comes to a head and there's
this hardcore chase scene which is oh my
gosh badass awesome which I like that it
didn't concentrate on the street races
and all that it was a heist movie the
end of the movie was like the freeway
scene and bad boys do but like a lot
longer with two cars carrying pretty
much a big wrecking ball and [ __ ] got
destroyed and Jeremy smiled a lot and
now
talks in the third person I guess I mean
Paul Walker's still like Keanu Reeves
with a tan and Vin Diesel still talks
like he has his whole fist in his mouth
but all in all I found the movie
surprisingly enjoyable then again maybe
all Fast & Furious movies are this
enjoyable but I was just really
surprised I liked this movie or at least
found it fun some scenes defy logic
others defy physics logic beam when
you're trying to maintain a low profile
don't street race like I said it doesn't
concentrate on the street racing but
they street race in really high profile
cars while they're on these little
intercoms that the cars have the luck
all right after we do this job I'm gonna
take your I'll bet you a million dollars
we all beat you Daniel Ocean would not
put up with that [ __ ] he would slap you
all in the head and slap himself in the
head for doing Ocean's Twelve if you
liked the fast in the Furious movies
this is like your Holy Grail this is
like your Passion of the Christ of fast
and furious movies so you would give
fast live awesome tacular I'm not going
to buy the movie on blu-ray but I was
surprised at how cool I found it so I
will say it's a good time no alcohol
required if I had to pay full price for
this movie I'd walk out of there going
it's pretty cool I'm not a grease monkey
I'm not a car head I'm not I Drive a
Saturn that's right ladies I am that
cool but if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more